air pollution is a huge problem around
the world and we know it impacts our
health now we know about how much toxic
air shortens our lives by 20 months on
average that's according to the health
effects Institute in their latest report
the state of global air now that 20
number is an average when you break
things down region by region you can see
how Asian out in South Asia children
lose 30 months of their lives in East
Asia people lose an estimated 23 months
that is five times higher or maybe a
better way to think about it is five
times worse than what you have in North
America or Western Europe pollution is
now a bigger killer than malaria and
road accidents it's as bad as smoking
here's a closer look
donning a face mask part of the morning
routine for many school kids in Delhi
where toxic smog engulfs the city for
much of the year some days twenty times
about the WHU shows of recommended limit
for dangerous fine particles in the air
india is home to 14 of the world's most
polluted cities exposure to air
pollution cuts the life expectancy of
kids thereby two and a half years by
increasing their risk of chronic heart
and lung disease among other illnesses
Delhi's toxic air hit home for one
mother when her young son fell ill I
also felt that my son was falling sick a
lot with the pollution you know he was
getting a lot of these allergic coughs
and colds and it's at that time actually
that we realize that they're the problem
was really alarming in China the entire
population breathe air that exceeds the
wh o--'s safety standard toxic air
accounted for 1.2 million deaths in
China in 2017 air pollution has dropped
in recent years due to government
efforts to curb emissions
but this time-lapse in Beijing shows the
blankets of smog that worry many parents
happy yeah the doctor says she's sick
because of smog she was in the hospital
for six days because of this I just
picked her up to the north and
Mongolia's capital Ulaanbaatar our
reliance on coal for heating has turned
the air hazardous families are making
hard choices this mother makes a
three-hour round-trip each week to see
her daughter who now lives with her
grandparents in the countryside under
doctor's orders after two bouts of
pneumonia
Amina's immune system couldn't cope with
the city air I think she got sick
because of the smoke we were surrounded
by it now she has fresh air she hasn't
gotten sick she will get a sniffle here
and there but that usually passes easily
there Exodus a stark warning for the
future of much of Asia's urban areas
choking on dirty air joining me now is
Dan Greenbaum one of the authors of the
study Dan now that we're armed with this
data and this information has any of the
governments responded well we've seen
responses in in places around the world
certainly there have been actions
announced in places like India with
their new national clean air program and
they are now saying well we really need
to be serious about trying to implement
this and I think it's going to be an
important part of their election
discussion that they're having currently
the good news is that in China we report
that they have started to take action so
they've seen improvement but they still
have quite a ways to go now you talk
about China in the report as a fairly
standout country are there other
countries that are doing a relatively
good job compared to countries that are
not really doing much well they they
really are at the leading edge of the
pack of the developing and emerging
economies in terms of taking action
about air pollution India has started to
they have a new program to put natural
gas into homes instead of burning solid
fuels they are recall it requiring
cleaner vehicles the cleanest vehicles
by 2020 but it's going to take a long
time in those countries to deal with
these these problems the other part of
the world that really needs to this kind
of attention Eastern Europe has just
started to deal with what fuels are
burnt in homes and how those affect
outdoor air pollution now there are
things that governments can do at the
macro level but I wonder what an
individual can do to better improve the
air they breathe one thing that I look
at is I see a lot of people in Asia with
the face masks and I've always wondered
do they really work what personal
actions can people take well face masks
actually if they're well designed can
help reduce the exposure but they're not
going for the most part to be the major
answer to this question children can't
be wearing these if they're at home and
a creative or other place that they're
not going to be able to do that I can't
believe I think a couple of things first
of all just in your daily actions if you
use less electricity if you drive less
if you do other things that can reduce
the emissions you have a lot of control
to do that secondly there are on the
market some of them are quite well
machines that can filter the air coming
into a half into a house so at least for
your children inside their home they
would be cleaner but the number one
thing is really that personal action to
say I'm gonna use less energy which
hopefully will reduce air pollution for
everyone dan Greenbaum thank you thanks
for having me